[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a fantasy film called miss
peregrine's home for peculiar children
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie we see a
teenager named jake portman working in a
grocery store jake gets a call from his
dad asking him to be at his grandfather
abe's home abe is a patient with
dementia and needs to be taken care of
at all times his co-worker offers to
give him a ride when he reaches home he
sees his grandfather missing jake and
his co-worker go around looking for him
after a while he finds abe on the ground
with both his eyeballs missing
before jake can react abe grabs his hand
asking him to go back to september 3rd
using a postcard to meet a bird
suddenly abe stops talking and takes his
last breath
jake freezes in shock just then he
notices a massive monster in the dark
the monster goes away when his colleague
accidentally shoots in his direction
although jake believes that abe's final
words were just gibberish the monster he
saw that day had a huge impact on his
mental health it is now a month after
abe's death jake has started going to
therapy he tells his therapist about
stories abe used to tell him when he was
a child abe always talked about a home
for special children somewhere in
cairnholm an island off the coast of
wales
the home was run by a strict but caring
lady named peregrine who could turn into
a bird there lived children with unique
qualities the ones who didn't fit in the
normal society like bronwyn and victor
who had superhuman strength hugh who had
bees living inside him and emma who
could float abe even had pictures of the
children he talked about jake believed
his stories for years until he talked
about them in a middle school class
presentation his classmates made fun of
him for believing such absurd ideas so
jake angrily accused abe of lying and
from that day onwards abe never
mentioned the children's home the
therapist thinks that jake is having a
hard time separating abe's fantasies
from reality that is why he hallucinated
the monster that day
later when jake returns home his aunt
gives him a book she had found in abe's
belongings inside the book is a postcard
that has miss peregrine's name and the
children's home address written on it
jake shows it to his therapist in the
following session she suggests he visit
the place so he and abe can have a
proper closure the very next day jake
and his father leave for wales the two
finally reach the town and check into an
old hotel jake goes to the children's
home to find it fully destroyed when he
returns a man tells him that in 1943 a
nazi missile landed on the children's
home and destroyed it killing everyone
inside
the following day jake goes back to the
home and looks around when suddenly a
girl appears in front of him startled he
starts to run falls down and is knocked
unconscious
when he regains consciousness he is
being carried by bronwyn the girl from
his grandfather's story who has
superhuman strength he sees other
characters from the story in front of
him jake is shocked but delighted to see
that the stories are true emma the girl
who can float tells jake that they are
sent by miss peregrine to bring him into
the loop they take him inside a cave but
jake gets nervous and runs back to his
hotel there he comes across unfamiliar
faces who ask him who he is it turns out
that after entering the cave he traveled
back in time to september 3rd 1943. the
people in the hotel think that he is a
spy and are about to kill him when the
children from earlier save him they take
him to the children's home where he
finally meets miss peregrine inside a
girl named olive is boiling tea with her
hands showing that she can create fire
with them miss peregrine reveals to him
that the children's home was established
to accommodate people born with unique
qualities called the peculiars such
unique qualities are acquired as
recessive genes and can show itself in
any generation children's homes like
this are spread throughout the world to
protect the peculiars from normal people
every children's home is run by a breed
of peculiar called the imbrines embryons
can freeze time and repeat it and also
shapeshift into birds hence miss
peregrine being an imbrine resets the
time every day the people of the
children's home have been reliving
september 3rd 1943 for as long as they
can remember abe used to live in the
children's home when he was little and
the children jake met earlier were his
grandfather's friends since they live in
a loop they haven't aged jake is shocked
at the revelation he asks miss peregrine
what abe's power was but she dismisses
him
while roaming around the house jake
meets a peculiar named enoch whose
ability is that he can make the dead
people and inanimate objects come to
life as his puppet at supper it is
revealed that abe left the children's
home to join the army he also finds out
that emma used to be in love with abe
when he was around after that everyone
sits down to watch a movie a peculiar
named horus can project his dreams onto
the wall and can also dream of the
future they watch horace's dream like a
movie after the movie everyone goes
outside to watch peregrine reset time
jake watches in awe as she stops the
missile from being dropped in the house
and resets the time to september 3rd
again jake then finds a letter written
to miss peregrine by his grandfather and
keeps it with him emma takes jake to the
cave to get him out of the loop as they
walk an injured imbrain bird lands in
front of them emma takes the bird and
goes back to the house as jake comes out
of the loop when he's back in the hotel
jake reads the letter he had stolen in
the letter abe warns peregrine of
someone named baron who has been trying
to harm peculiars of another loop the
following day jake's dad takes him to a
beach to watch birds there they meet an
ornithologist named john jake's dad who
watches birds as a hobby is annoyed by
jon so they return to the hotel jake
waits for his father to fall asleep and
goes back into the loop he asks miss
peregrine about baron but miss peregrine
is mad at him for being intrusive and
doesn't answer his question enoch takes
him to a peculiar named victor but jake
is shocked to see victor's dead body
lying on a bed then enoch places a heart
into his body and makes him his puppet
demonstrating his power when they later
go on a walk he asks emma about baron to
answer his question emma takes him under
the sea and into the remains of a sunken
ship she uses her power to manipulate
air and makes the chamber water free she
then hands him a box and claims that it
belonged to abe inside is a map of every
loop of the world and pictures of some
peculiars
one of them is baron the leader of a
group of bad peculiars called the
hollows she tells him that abe left the
children's home to hunt them but
couldn't hollows look for the peculiar
kids and kill them only peregrine knows
what their real motive is emma then
takes jake to watch peregrine killing a
monster similar to the one jake saw when
abe died emma says that no one other
than abe and jake can see the monster
even peregrine is using her time
manipulation skills to kill it it turns
out that jake is also a peculiar just
like his grandfather and both of their
skills are that they can see invisible
monsters when they are back at the
children's home peregrine tells jake
about hollows and their origin
hollows were regular peculiars who were
tired of living in loops they believed
that harnessing the essence of imbrine's
powers would make them immortal and they
could live outside the loop without
aging so they abducted anembrine and
conducted an experiment however the
experiment failed turning the hollows
into invisible monsters to go back to
their human form they had to feed on
peculiar's eyes hollows started
abducting peculiar children for their
eyes baron and some of his friends
regained their human forms but their
eyes remained milky white some monsters
are still looking for children's eyes to
feed on
as she finishes telling the story miss
avacet regains consciousness she is the
imbrine that emma had found in the cave
earlier miss avacet tells them that the
children's home she was a caretaker of
has been completely destroyed by the
monsters who killed all her children for
their eyes baron is planning to conduct
the experiment again this time by using
more embryons his next target is
peregrine's children's home hearing this
miss peregrine quickly asks the kids to
pack their bags she wants to change the
loop so they can be safer emma asks jake
to come with them to the other loop
however jake denies it and goes back to
the island exiting the loop when he
reaches the beach he sees a crowd
gathering around a dead body his dad and
the ornithologist john are there too
jake notices the dead body's eyes have
been taken he realizes that the hollows
are already here and runs towards the
cave to warn miss peregrine jon offers
jake's dad to bring him back and follows
him he enters the cave behind jake it is
revealed that jon is actually barren who
has been using his shape-shifting
abilities to disguise himself he reveals
that he also disguised himself as jake's
therapist to get jake to the island and
find the location of the loop through
him he then threatens jake to take him
to the children's home
miss peregrine is shocked to see baron
at her door with no way out she offers
to go with baron if he leaves the
children out of this after the two leave
miss avacet and jake close all the doors
and windows to the house and gather
weapons since baron knows where they are
he can send his monster friends to hunt
the children for their eyes suddenly an
invisible monster attacks miss avacet
when jake is not around it kills the
poor lady but is injured by jake right
after
everyone then runs to the attic and
escapes through a tree branch since
peregrine is not here to restart the
loop the day changes to september 4th
and the nazi missile drops on the house
thankfully everyone is safe once they
are out of the loop they plan to go to
the black loop where baron is conducting
the experiment using miss peregrine and
the other embryons they get on a ship
and continue the journey using abe's map
they finally get to a carnival jake and
emma enter the black loop which takes
them back to 2016. they see baron his
friends and some monsters inside jake
uses emma to provoke baron making him
send the monsters and two of his men
outside to kill the children but the
children have already planned a way to
defeat them they throw snow at those men
revealing the shape of the monsters
meanwhile enoch makes a bunch of
skeletons his puppets and sends them to
fight the monsters then the children
make their way to baron and his friends
they fight them using their unique
powers and managed to defeat everyone
except for baron jake releases the
imbrines from the cages including miss
peregrine but they cannot help him since
they are injured now baron and jake
stand face to face when suddenly baron
shapeshifts into jake emma and enoch
come inside and are confused about which
is the real jake they point a crossbow
at them as both try to prove they are
the real jake just then a monster enters
the room the monster mistakes baron for
jake and attacks him sucking his eyes
and killing him finally jake kills the
monster and everyone is safe
before the time loop closes jake says
goodbye to the children as they exit and
return to their ship in 1943 while he
stays in 2016. jake travels to his home
in florida to see abe is still alive it
turns out baron's death at the beginning
of 2016 erased his presence in florida
later on jake is delighted and tells abe
everything that has happened abe asks
jake to go back to emma as she is
waiting for him jake takes his advice
and travels the world going into many
loops to look for emma and the others he
finally finds them on the ship still
traveling jake tells emma that he loves
her and the two finally kiss the movie
ends as miss peregrine flies above the
ship overlooking the kids
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching